Hello and welcome to
YouTube Behind the Scenes.
My name is Mat’as Molinas
and I am a Google Developer
Expert for YouTube APIs.
In this lesson
we will see how to use
the YouTube iFrame
Embedded Player
on your pages
and your web applications.
We will also see
how you can personalize it
through parameters.
We will also analyze real cases
where the Player is configured
the same way.
And we will see how to implement
one of these cases.
Are you ready?
Let's get started.
INTRODUCTION TO
IFRAME EMBEDDED PLAYER
There are different options
for the Embedded Player.
There's the Flash AS3, AS2
Embedded Player
and also the Embedded
Player in an iFrame.
The iFrame is the most
recommended option
because this way
YouTube can decide
which Player will be downloaded
in the iFrame to play videos.
It's worth remembering
that there are devices
that can not support Flash,
such as iPad and iPhone.
There are two ways to create
an iFrame Embedded Player,
one is through JavaScript,
and the other by directly
declaring the iFrame.
In this lesson,
to make it easier,
we will directly declare
an iFrame to use URL parameters
that modify its appearance
and behavior.
The simplest way
for obtaining code
to embed the iFrame Player
is by using the code
shown in the Share option
when we watch a YouTube video.
The Embedded Player
has a series,
of standard controls.
such as the Play Button,
Pause Button,
Volume Control,
Progress BarÉ
We can personalize these
through parameters
as well as Player behavior.
We do this through
URL parameters.
We also specify through the URL
the video we want to watch.
We can use, for example,
the Autoplay parameter,
and this way the video
will begin automatically
with no user intervention.
Other than for personalizing
the Player by parameters,
the API allows us
to monitor its activities
and control it
through JavaScript.
But we'll see this
in the next lesson.
Now let's see
how to easily include
an iFrame instead of a Player
on a web page.
}STEP 1 -OBTAIN CODE
FROM AN IFRAME EMBED PLAYER
Select a video to play
on YouTube.
In the options below the video
select Share and Embed.
Select the size
you want the video to be
on your web page.
Copy the code shown.
This code allows you to include
the video on your page
through an iFrame
Embedded Player.
}STEP 2
TRY IT ONLINE
Try the code on this web page.
THE PARAMETERS
AND THEIR OPTIONS
Let's see how to personalize
the appearance and the behavior
of the YouTube Embedded Player
through URL parameters.
After this section,
you will be able to personalize
the YouTube Player
you use on your web pages
and your web applications
with no trouble.
Always remember
that your Player
should have a size of at least
200x200 pixels.
Other than personalizing
the appearance and behavior
of the Player
through parameters,
you can do it
through JavaScript.
In this case, you should include
one more URL parameter.
Personalization
through JavaScript
is what we will see
in the next lesson.
These are the parameters
we can use:
Before analyzing the parameters
in detail,
we should see the URL format
that allows us to embed a video
and specify what video
we want to see.
Let's see some of these
parameters in detail.
AUTOHIDE
Let's look at AutoHide.
This parameter indicates
if the Player hides the Controls
after the video begins to play.
It can have
the following values:
The first is 2,
which is by default.
In this case the Progress Bar
is visible during play.
Play and Volume Controls
are also visible.
The second is 1.
If we give it a 1 value,
the Progress Bar
and the Controls
slide away a few seconds
after the video starts to play,
but they become visible again
if the user scrolls the mouse
over the Player
or presses a key.
If the value is set on 0,
the Controls will be visible
while the video plays,
even if it's on Full Screen.
AUTOPLAY
Let's look at AutoPlay.
This parameter specifies
if the video
starts to play automatically
when the Player finishes
downloading on the page,
or if the user needs
to click on Play to start it.
It can have
the following values:
The first is 0,
which is by default.
In this case the user must click
on Play to start the video.
The second is 1,
and in this case,
the video
begins to play automatically
when the Player finishes
downloading on the web page.
CC_LOAD_POLICY
Now let's look at the
cc_load_policy parameter.
This parameter,
with the value set on 1,
makes subtitles appear
even if the user
did not select any subtitles.
This parameter only works
with Flash Player.
So, if the iFrame Player,
instead of the Flash Player,
downloaded the HTML5 Player,
because it's the only one
the device supports,
this parameter
will have no effect.
COLOR
This parameter establishes
the color of the Progress Bar
that shows what the user
has already seen.
This parameter
can have two values:
Red, which is the default value,
or White.
This parameter is ignored
if we use a parameter
that we will see further along,
which is ModestBranding.
CONTROLS
This parameter specifies
if Play Controls will be shown.
When Flash Player is used,
it also specifies if the Player
will download immediately.
If the value is 0,
the Controls will not appear
and Flash Player
will download immediately.
If the value is 1,
Player Controls will appear,
and if it's a Flash Player,
immediately start downloading.
If the value is 2,
Player Controls
will also appear,
but if it's a Flash Player,
it will download
when it starts to play.
LOOP
Now let's look at
the Loop parameter.
The Loop parameter
determines if a video,
or a playlist,
plays indefinitely.
The default value is 0,
and with this option,
the video or playlist,
will not play indefinitely.
If the value is 1,
it plays indefinitely
if it's a video,
and if it's a playlist,
we will see
the first to the last video,
and then it will repeat
indefinitely from the first.
MODESTBRANDING
Parameter ModestBranding.
This parameter establishes
if we will see the YouTube logo
on the Control Bar.
If this parameter
has a value of 1,
we will not see the logo,
but we will see text
in the upper right-hand corner
that says "YouTube"
when we scroll the mouse
over the Player
or when we stop the video.
The default value is 0,
and it indicates that
we will see the YouTube logo
on the Control Bar.
PLAYLIST
Parameter Playlist.
This parameter is used
to allow the player
to show a list of videos.
We will specify the video IDs
separated by commas,
and the video specified
on the video ID
will be the first video
to be played.
REL
Parameter Rel.
This parameter establishes if,
when a video is done playing,
recommendations
will be presented
for related videos, or not.
The value can be 0.
If this value is assigned,
recommendations will not show
at the end of the video.
If the value is 1,
which is the default value,
recommendations
for related videos
will show
at the end of the video.
SHOWINFO
Parameter ShowInfo.
This parameter indicates
if video information will show,
such as the Title
or Uploading Account,
before playing.
Value 0 for this parameter
makes the information invisible.
The value by default is 1,
and the Information,
Video Title, and Uploading
Account can be seen.
START
Parameter Start.
This parameter
can have a positive value,
which will be
the number of seconds
from when the video
starts to play.
If this point does not match up
with a frame,
it will search for a prior one
in order to start playing.
THEME
Parameter Theme.
This parameter determines
which Theme,
or combination of colors,
we will use
for the Player Control Bar.
The possible values are Dark,
which color combination
we will use on the Control Bar,
or Light, which is another
combination of colors
we can use for the Control Bar.
ANALYSIS OF REAL CASES
HOW TO IMPLEMENT A REAL CASE
FROM ZERO
Now let's see
how we can use the parameters
in real cases.
BELEZA
Let's look at
the real case of Beleza.
At the end of the video
we can see
the use of the Rel parameter,
because instead of showing
YouTube recommendations,
recommendations are shown
almost at the end of the video
as annotations.
AHHH
Now let's look at the Ahhh case.
In this case we can also
inspect the code
and see what parameters
are being used for the URL.
What is the effect of using
this combination of parameters?
Was Player appearance
and behavior as expected?
TU BRINDIS
Let's look at one more case,
the Tu Brindis case.
As in the other examples,
we can also inspect the code
and see the parameters
in the URL.
Let's see the effect
in the real case.
I hope you enjoyed this lesson.
We learned
how to use URL parameters
to personalize not only
the visual appearance,
but also the behavior
of the YouTube Player,
achieving a customized
experience.
We used the iFrame Player
parameters,
which is the option
that guarantees
your video can be seen
on most devices.
We also did it
using an iFrame tag,
which is the easiest way,
and, in many cases,
is more than enough.
We saw how to use the parameters
in real cases;
in successful cases.
I invite you to watch
the next lesson,
where we will see
how to use the iFrame API,
and the Flash API,
and how to control the Player,
but from JavaScript.
In the next lesson
we will also see all this
by looking at successful
real cases.
See you at the next lesson!